[Música]
gente estou super feliz aqui as têm um
contato com a santa maria superbom meu
pai se criou nessa cidade
meus avós até pouco tempo atrás moravam
aqui também e eu estou de volta e
principalmente agora no ted x baita
baita honra muito obrigado pelo convite
bom como já foi falado gente eu sou o
rafinha é esse sou eu sou um cara que
gosta bastante de viajar
então trouxe uma foto da última viagem
que eu fiz para o peru e com minha
namorada a gente foi de ônibus até lá
foi super legal
aí ela na foto e uma cachorra chamada
linha por linha adoro ela tá 12 anos da
minha vida já e manda lá em casa hoje
sobre rabugenta cachorro velho que fica
latindo
mas eu adoro é um cara que gosta
bastante de falar em público e essa
paixão descobriu há três anos atrás e ao
mesmo tempo também goste entender como
as pessoas se relacionam como grupo se
comporta
eu me apresento assim porque acredito
que quando a gente se apresentar com a
abertura ea gente fala de coisas que a
gente realmente gosta é a seguinte
relação com as pessoas assim que a gente
crie engajamento e meu top tem tudo a
ver sobre isso hoje mais ou menos duas
semanas atrás eu fiz um post no facebook
era mais uma aula de três horas onde só
uma pessoa falava no grupo de 40
o professor esse post foi muito legal
assim uma galera veio falar comentar
curtiu é muito professor muito aluno
muita gente que estava querendo falar
sobre esse assunto eu milito de uma
coisa a gente não tá acostumado com
espaço de abertura e quando a gente tem
esse espaço de conversa a gente fala
infelizmente esse espaço hoje não existe
dentro das escolas nem dentro das
universidades e se reflete nas empresas
a sociedade como um todo a culpa na
pessoa central
ou seja estou falando de uma sala de
aula culpa desse espaço não saber do
professor
estou falando de uma palestra a culpa
dessa palestra ser ruim do palestrante
eu espero não ser ruim hoje mas essas
coisas vão se multiplicando da escola
para a universidade da universidade para
as empresas e até na nossa vida
quem já teve uma aula com slide
eu até fiquei mais bonitinho assim vou
ter umas fotos boas e tal mas eu usei
começamos então não conta
gente esse slide assim como aquela hora
aula monólogo pode ser o grande fator
porque uma aula chata do que uma aula
não é aberta
eu acredito fortemente nisso eu trago
slide eu trago aquele post porque há
três anos atrás eu tive um seminário em
sala de aula que resolvi fazer ele com
toda a paixão no meu mundo
eu fiz uma apresentação que tinha um
roteiro interessante eu fiz uma
apresentação tinha um design elegante
naquele momento eu mudei ambiente quando
inserido o professor foi engajado os
alunos querem engajados simplesmente
porque a apresentação era muito boa que
eu apresentei com brilho no olho
essa oportunidade que eu tive três anos
atrás se tornou um negócio que hoje
minha paixão é me levou para vários
lugares inclusive um dia um professor
britânico me ligou me mandou um e-mail é
conhecer um amigo dele que era amigo de
um amigo meu enfim pela conexão
esse cara me ligou e pediu que a gente
faz uma apresentação no seminário para
ele a impressão mais bonita
eu falei claro vamos fazer projeto foi
super legal eu não sei como é que ele
chegou a gente não sei onde é que ele
não chorou mas o que eu sei que ele
pague blues então tá tudo bem mas enfim
esse problema ele acontece no mundo
inteiro
as apresentações em sala de aula não são
boas
então naquele momento mais ou menos uns
quatro meses de trabalho e mais dois
amigos gente acabou de criar um negócio
tinha e ainda tem como missão conectar
professores e alunos através das boas
apresentações em sala de aula
a gente vai fazendo esse trabalho
atendendo professores alunos enfim a
gente foi entendendo que a apresentação
ela tem um valor mas é um valor muito
limitado
se vocês pensarem a apresentação ela não
passa de uma ferramenta não adianta nada
eu tenho uma apresentação superbonita
atrás de mim e eu não ser um bom
comunicador e ao contrário se eu for um
bom comunicador
muitas vezes eu nem preciso de uma
apresentação em 3d mim e pensei comigo a
apresentação nada mais é do que a
extensão do
tas que a gente fazendo ensino médio a
diferença é que no cartaz a gente botava
a nossa criatividade na apresentação a
gente não coloca nem existe o cara que
não faz nada no trabalho na faculdade e
se o cara que passa os slides
naquela época o cara que segurava um
cartaz então a ferramenta é a mesma do
jeito que a gente está usando ela
a gente começou a entender que isso é só
uma ferramenta e começou a buscar outras
soluções para que professores se
comunicassem melhor para que alunos
tivessem melhor comunicação
relacionamento mais interessante e para
que empresas também pudessem ter sido
essa comunicação é interessante porque
isso na sala de aula acontece isso
quando chega na conferência do encontro
de líderes das capacitações empresariais
isso também acontece a gente acabou
descobrindo que as pessoas não conseguem
criar elos dentro do seu ambiente
professores e alunos não se conectam
livre sua equipe não se conectam os
encontros corporativos que a gente tinha
que fazer então era tranqüila
apresentação lançar um pouco mais mais
alto
o pt é só o final a gente precisa pensar
antes como as pessoas se relacionam
nesses ambientes
a gente precisava criar um espaço de
abertura de partes onde as pessoas se
desvencilha sem daquele pt bonito e
entendessem como elas podem se
relacionar com o público e com o seu
grupo então foram três anos entendendo
dinâmicas de grupo como a gente podia
desenhar mais esses espaços de abertura
como a gente podia tê-la as
apresentações com essas habilidades de
relacionamento das pessoas de
comunicação e dentro desses três anos a
gente deu vários professores e empresas
e alunos e eu queria trazer para vocês
hoje cinco daqueles pilares que eu
considero principais como a gente vai
criar esse espaço de engajamento de
abertura
acredito que esses cinco pilares e se
você estiver em uma apresentação bonita
trás você também é o espaço de vocês
assim muito mais engajado o primeiro
pilar seria a horizontalidade
infelizmente hoje a gente tem uma idéia
clara hierarquiza são muito grande
dentro da sala de aula
hoje a gente tem alguém que ensina
alguém que aprendi
e essa pessoa que ensinam normalmente é
o centro de tudo essa pessoa aqui a
gente precisa quebrar essa barreira e
para quebrar essa barreira agentes e
criar espaços horizontais onde as
pessoas que estão no grupo dentro do
ambiente de aprendizagem dentro da
empresa e por aí vai
tem os mesmos papéis de aprender e de
ensinar onde todos possam compartilhar
idéias e conteúdo e que todos possam
aprender juntos
por isso a horizontalidade é tão
importante pilar 21 no olho e agora
queria fazer uma dinâmica com vocês lá
vem o chato na dinâmica do processo
levantarem um pouquinho eu vou pedir pra
vocês olharem para o colega do lado de
vocês e olhar bem no fundo do olho do
colega
veja um acordo o olho do colega muito
bem podem sentar para enfrentar a
brigada gente esse exercício é
desconfortável muitas vezes
muita gente estava rindo e fazendo
brincadeira é porque é difícil a gente
não está acostumado a olhar no olho das
pessoas e não adianta nada ter a
apresentação superbonita se apresentou
no teto é mais louco louco se não
tivesse contato visual
em relação à anterior com vocês por isso
o olho no olho é tão importante
infelizmente muitas vezes ele não
acontece no espaço que a gente tá
terceiro pilar a abertura hoje eu
pratiquei esse pilar com vocês eu falei
que eu tenho uma cachorrinha chamada
linha
eu falei que eu gosto de viajar que o
peru que eu namoro miami enfim eu falei
várias coisas que me fazem feliz e eu
tenho certeza que quando eu falei da
bolinha
muitas pessoas que têm cachorro muitas
pessoas também têm um cachorro chamado
de linha se relacionaram comigo quando
eu falei que eu viajei que eu fui pro
peru muitas pessoas também se relacionar
por que por que me abre com você
num primeiro momento que eu pude a
abertura o primeiro passo para a gente
criar relacionamento e ela também não
acontece a gente tem um pouco de medo de
mostrar as coisas que a gente realmente
gosta a gente prefere na verdade e falar
sobre nosso currículo que a gente
informado que a gente já fez mas a gente
não fala que a gente gosta de comer tal
coisa de fazer uma coisa é assim que a
gente cria relações fortes de confiança
com as pessoas
o quarto pilar seria escuta atenta seja
usar uma resenha dos dedinhos pra falar
em algum grupo
a regra dos edis ela funciona da
seguinte maneira digamos que eu esteja
falando a próxima pessoa que quiser
falar
levanto número 1 essa pessoa é fechar um
na fila da fala
só que enquanto eu tô falando a pessoa
está com o dedo levantado ela já não
está mais nem aí pra mim essa pessoa já
está pensando na construção dos seus
argumentos para talvez até desconstruir
os meus
imagina então quem está com o número 3
que está com o número 3 já não está mais
aqui já baixou o santo já foi embora
a escuta atenta para mim é o pilar que -
acontece a gente tem um imediatismo
absurdo para dar respostas a gente não
pode tomar dez segundos para pensar
o professor perguntou 'não te responder
o aluno perguntou professor aproxima
pode não saber falar é importante
primeiro a gente escutar as pessoas com
atenção e segundo a gente não dá nos dar
o espaço de construir a nossa resposta
entendeu que aquela pessoa realmente
está falando e o quinto pilar eo último
que acredito que talvez seja até natural
depois que já tenha cumprido os outros
quatro
depois que já criou um ambiente
horizontal depois que tudo já praticou
abertura depois que já olhou no olho das
pessoas entendeu que elas querem e
depois que já escutou as pessoas
entendam se realmente aquele conteúdo é
relevante para ela a confiança acaba
vindo naturalmente de novo
infelizmente a gente não tem confiança
no ambiente de aprendizagem e muito
menos nas empresas
a confiança também vêm a longo prazo
então não adianta numa primeira reunião
de trabalho ou quem sabe uma primeira
aula eu
tenho confiança nos meus alunos dos meus
alunos com o professor a confiança na
quebra de barreiras
a gente vai se abrindo a gente vai se
relacionando até que a gente gera essa
confiança é importante também porque
quando a gente tem confiança no público
o público na gente
a gente também tem autoconfiança ea
gente pode falhar a gente pode mostrar
nossas fraquezas porque não importa mais
confiança
já nesse espaço bom eu trouxe pra vocês
cinco pilares coisas que eu acredito e
eu sou um cara que trabalha com
apresentações já que ficou pt no final
do estudo
o pt é acabou de assumir o papel que ele
nunca deveria ter parado de assumir o
papel de ferramenta papel de uma
ferramenta que precisa ser bem planejada
e bem utilizada para que a nossa
comunicação seja compartilhado de uma
forma legal
o papel de ferramenta que nada mais é do
que um guia
a gente precisa primeiro pensar de como
a gente vai se relacionar com as pessoas
que estão à nossa volta para depois
pensar sem apresentação tem que ser
bonita ou feia só depois pensar eu sei
que eu tenho que usar uma fonte outro
primeiro a gente precisa criar
relacionamento
depois a gente embeleza tudo isso com
uma apresentação muito bem feita no
começo da palestra eu falei sobre um
post no facebook e um amigo meu comentou
um negócio que achei muito interessante
eu queria dizer pra vocês
mateus falou o seguinte o professor tem
um papel central de mediador da mudança
e transformação em grande parte dos
processos
e quando falo professora que eu falo a
pessoa central dentro dos grupos pode
ser um aluno talvez no seminário pode
ser o professor realmente pode ser
também um líder dentro da sua equipe
essas pessoas têm a capacidade de abrir
os espaços de engajamento e elas não
podem mais ficar esperando que o grupo
responda
elas têm que tomar a iniciativa elas
precisam assumir cada vez mais papéis de
plataforma
ou seja elas precisam se tornar
plataformas para que o grupo por si só e
entenda como esse grupo aprende como
esse grupo ensina e como esse grupo
compartilha e aí sim esse grupo pode
alcançar seus objetivos
tem um cenário que eu acredito que seja
o cenário ideal
isso tem alguma coisa que eu quero é ver
a minha palestra
tirando a piadinha da minha namorada
lema é esse cenário é esse cenário que
estou tentando construir uma
universidade que vocês podem construir
aqui também é o cenário onde o aluno
ajuda o professor a ensinar e na outra
mão o aluno o professor ajuda o aluno a
aprender muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]